monsieur touche man m'a assuré que ces
élèves sont extrêmement gentils en
particulier ceux julian il paraît c'est
un ange non pas un ange il fait partie
des gosses qui se comportent d'une
certaine manière devant les adultes et
est différemment devant les autres
enfants ouais c'est ça bon je sais que
c'est dur mais il faut que tu comprennes
qui n'a probablement pas une haute
estime de lui lorsque certaines
personnes ont des actes musquin doit
prendre sur toile passer outre
ok ok ce garçon a l'air d'être un vrai
cri d'un cybercentre du mal à remettre à
sa place
il ne faut pas avoir peur de riposter
battu par tomas pays il faut que tu
prennes sur toi et que tu passes au
tracé facile
quelqu'un peut me dire ce que ce mot
signifie personnes non des préceptes
sont des règles qui concernent les
choses importantes de la vie comme les
devises tout à fait ou ou comme les
citations célèbres ou encore les
prédictions à l'intérieur d'un fortune
cookies par exemple un précepte peut
nous aider à nous motiver et il peut
nous guider quand on doit prendre une
décision importante dans notre vie vous
voyez bon qui veut nous lire le précepte
du moins dis-moi comment tu t'appelles
toi seigneur sommer tu nous lis ça
lorsqu'on a le choix d'être juste avec
quelqu'un ou d'être gentil il faut être
gentil
je te retrouves
après les sept bars voilà
je t'aime très rarement aussi
à tout à l'heure
tu m'entends s'il te regardent
bizarrement fait pas attention se font
jamais dans la masse quand on est né
pour briller
faut qu'on ait une discussion d'homme à
homme bon je peux pas aller plus loin on
à partir de là c'est une zone interdite
au papa et oui tu peux pas arriver en
haut la main de tes parents si tu vas
avoir l'air cool mais toi tu coules oui
c'est vrai mais en général les terres
sont pas très cool et portait un casque
c'est pas cool non plus
il ya deux règles importantes
la première de lève la main qu'une seule
fois en classe même si tu sais les
réponses enfin sous for science là il
faut que tu kartonn hockey la deuxième
tu vas avoir l'impression d'être seuls
au monde
mais c'est pas le cas ok allez on enlève
salle fait voir les déguisements c'est
pour halloween paréo lance moore
je tape à moi aussi je t'aime amuse-toi
bien au revoir
il arrive lentement
seigneur fait qu'il soit je retiens
trois
après new show
souvent
je